bonjour qui parmi vous et déjà grands
parents pourrez vous s'il vous plaît les
v la main oui et puis garder votre main
levée parce que vous allez répondre
positivement à la prochaine question qui
parmi vous et des jeux par an oui et
alors qui part mais vous êtes déjà étalé
au moins une fois dans votre vie
pourrait coûter un spectacle de contes
ou peut-être un balade contée whaou
génial super maintenant qui part mais
vous pratiquer l'art de conter au sein
de votre propre famille je ne parle pas
de la lecture de livres à haute voix je
parle de compte en réalité
félicitations bravo
oui moi je suis conteuse professionnelle
et je gagne ma vie en disons des comptes
avec ma parole mais comptait pour moi
c'est pas uniquement une question du
travail odt et gagner ma vie compte et
c'est ma passion
comptez c'est ma vocation
conti pour moi c'est essentiel et sens
ciel et aujourd'hui je voudrais vous
parler de quelque chose
un aspect de mon travail que kim et
tient à coeur c'est de mettre ou de
remettre l'art de conter au sein de la
famille je voudrais parler d'eux
pourquoi moi j'estime que c'est très
important que on compte dans nos
familles
et pour cela je vais vous raconter un
tout petit peu mon parcours je suis né
en écosse d'une famille nombreuse j'ai
six frères et soeurs je viens demain si
bonne famille ma famille m'a donné le
goût des livres j'adore toujours la
lecture légaux de la nature
et puis je reçu une bonne éducation je
suis globalement poli mais dans ma
famille l'oralité manquer combien de
fois n'ai je entendu les enfants doivent
être vues mais pas entendu et puis je me
rappelle un jour je devais avoir 12 ans
je rentrais d'une journée au collège je
sais pas ce que s'est passé je me
rappelle plus mais j'avais une forte
envie de dire ma journée à ma mère
lorsque je suis arrivé à la maison ma
mère faisait du repassage
je ne sais pas si vous pouvez imaginer
les piles de repassage que cet enfant de
plus elle même qui travaillait son mari
qui travaille ce que ça peut faire
ma mère elle n'était pas prête à
m'écouter et ce jour là j'étais déçu
j'étais triste j'étais fâché je me
disais mais ma mère elle ne m'écoute
jamais et puis le temps a fait son
travail
maintenant j'étais à paris j'avais
trente deux ans hélas ma vie a changé
pour la première fois de ma vie j'ai
entendu un compteur qui racontait des
histoires ono khalid et ses comptes sa
parole ça m'a ébloui
et puis ça m'a donné une forte envie de
me mettre en quête moi-même pour
comprendre les comptes pour entrer dans
ce monde
alors j'ai commencé à chercher j'ai fait
des stages je suis retourné en écosse
j'ai fait du collectage de comptes et au
bout d'un moment je suis revenu ici j'ai
commencé à les compter et puis et puis
au bout de cinq ans d'apprentissage je
suis devenue conteuse professionnelle et
là j'étais invité du nord du sud d'est
en ouest en france partout j'ai
rencontré b les mille paysages le
ministre o'neal villages les villes les
gens et les 10000 spécialité de la
nourriture française
puis au bout d'un moment avec
l'expérience j'avais envie de commencer
à aider à enseigner les comptes à aider
les apprentis adultes futurs compteurs
et j'ai découverte que j'adorais
enseigner j'adore ouvrir l'horizon un
peu plus grande pour l'autre j'adore
voir l'autre faire pousser les fleurs de
son propre talent
j'aime ça et donc à un moment donné j'ai
voulez savoir mais qu'est ce qui se
passe pour les enfants conteurs
comment les enfants peuvent compter et
j'étais invité dans les classes alors là
ça s'est passé tout jeu comme ça
j'arrivais je disais deux trois côtes
et puis je demander aux enfants est ce
que vous connaissez des comptes
ob les mains se laver il est titre sa
tombe et blanche neige le petit chaperon
rouge les trois petits cochons
la légende de la vie glisse j'étais en
finistère est alors du coup j'ai demandé
aux enfants alors je suis contente je
vois que vous connaissez vraiment
beaucoup de comptes qui pourrait dire un
compte
l'erreur enfants qui dit on dit un
compte devant leurs classes quelquefois
cité des enfants timides quelquefois
c'était des enfants ou même une fois un
enfant mon échec scolaire
quelquefois des enfants n'a si brillant
mais les rares enfants qui ont réussi à
dire en compte pour leur classe et
chaque fois que je disais mais d'où
viennent ces comptes il me parlait
toujours qui donne grand'mère qui donne
père qui d'un grand-père qui d'un grand
frère toujours les comptes en oralité
venez de l'imprégnation familiale et là
je me rappelais quand j'avais cherché
des contes collectés des comptes au
négoce j'ai collecté auprès des gens de
voyage écossais j'avais été émerveillés
par leur parole ces gens mais semblait
être commun puis inépuisable d'où
jaillissait une vivante deschamps semble
des contes des légendes des histoires de
la mémoire familiale de la mémoire
collective histoire des connaissances
heymans et il me disait qu'il entendait
des comptes avant de naître que dans
leur famille dans leur famille élargie
le compte était omniprésent tout le
monde comptait et il y avait des comptes
sur tous les sujets à l'intérieur du
compte et c'est comme ça que l ontt
élaborer leurs paroles des prix leur
enfance et surtout ils ont pris mais la
richesse culturelle contre leur pauvreté
matérielle est donc revenue en france
j'ai décidé de créer des ateliers contes
et en famille alors ça se passe
principe très simple un adulte grands
parents parents dont tati marraine par
un j'ai pas encore eu des parents mais
j'attends even vient toujours accompagné
de no2 enfants quelquefois c'est un
couple qui viennent avec leurs enfants
et la enfants et adultes
ensemble ils apprennent à compter
je ne sais pas si vous vous avez déjà
entendu à l'enfant compte et je ne sais
pas si vous avez entendu votre enfant
compter je me rappelle de cette petite
fille elle avait 5 ans et debbie elle
est venue avec sa marraine elle nous
racontait une histoire de princesse mais
sa princesse elle adoré monter galoper à
cheval de toute allure à brive battu à
travers les landes
cette française elle manier l'épée et
elle adorerait faire des joutes elle
gagné tandis que dans le conte son frère
le prince
il adorait jouer là à est composé des
morceaux de musique
or dans le conte leur père le roi il
était fermement décidé que des jeunes
filles doivent jouer sagement de la
musique et que les garçons il faut qu'il
soit fort je vous raconte pas la fin de
l'histoire mais ce compte là dans la
bouche de ces petits bouts de chou qui
était avec un homme avec une
détermination de dire son compte avec un
humour imbattable on était tous mourir
et puis à nous embarquer dans son compte
et une richesse de vocabulaire
c'était époustouflant un autre moment
donc un atelier je me rappelle d'un
grand père il est venu avec sa petite
fille de 10 ans son petit garçon de 8
ans cet homme avait subi un accident et
il avait perdu une
emma mais je n'oublierai jamais quand
pour la première fois de sa vie il a
compté un conte issus de la littérature
orale comme un dit si joliment jo je
n'oublierai jamais cette sourire qui a
inondé s'envisage tous en être
et puis pendant qu'il avait compté
javert écarter ses deux petits-enfants
et je voyais bien dans leurs yeux qu'ils
suivait toutes les péripéties du compte
mais surtout j'avais lu l admiration des
normes pour le grand père devenu conteur
et puis vous voyez sur la photo ici
c'est une petite fille on prétend qu'ils
viennent de terminer de dire son premier
conte regarde
regardez ça sur son sourire moi je les
qualifie les rayons non or ça tout ça ça
m'intriguait toutes ces sourires tout
cette sensation de bien être
quand les gens ne finissaient de compter
parce que je me disais c'est quelque
chose de plus que simplement le le fait
de terminer son compte
alors je me suis dit qu'est ce que c'est
parce dont l'acte de narration et moi
même je me rate je sais que lorsque je
compte
et bien je suis très très très vivante
littéralement comme si on venait
d'allumer une lumière en moi ne vienne à
lui mais je pense que vous pouvez garder
le deuxième somme c'est aussi mais je me
rappelle bien sciatique qui a duré huit
mois
jamais pendant que je comptais j'en
avais de douleurs jamais alors pour
trouver des réponses et comprendre
l'importance de la narration
je me suis tourné vers les neurosciences
de la narration
j'ai entendu parler d'un médecin et
psychiatre américain dr luis mail
madrona
qui lui comme les jambes de voyage en
écosse est né dans une famille de
peuples premiers des états unis les
lakotas et les créent ou les comptes est
omniprésent et tout le monde compte et
il ya des comptes sur tout et bien
devenu médecin psychiatre pour soulager
les souffrances de ses patients il
mélangeait la médecine occidentale avec
le guérit sans que les ennemis donc sa
tribu données et donc cette guérison
la narration et l'écoutent joue un rôle
important
alors je vais rapidement de vous dire
les choses que j'ai appris en lisant que
ces livres premium en notre cerveau elle
et il est fait pour la narration
deuxièmement si tom des scientifiques
britanniques les notre cerveau a été
évolué grâce à la narration
c'est pas parce que notre cerveau est
devenue plus grande que les primates que
les cerveaux a dit chouette chouette
chouette je vais faire de la narration
non c'est parce que nos ancêtres ont
commencé à faire l'acte narration que le
cerveau s'est développée et puis j'ai
appris que dans l'acte de narration tout
le cerveau est littéralement un briquet
dans cet acte
d'où les sensations de bien-être de être
très vivante et pris une dernière chose
j'ai appris qu'elle lorsque deux
personnes un compte
l'autre écoute leur cerveau se met au
diapason
ils sont littéralement sur les mêmes
longueurs d'onde
donc vous comprenez maintenant pourquoi
dans ma famille avec cette narration
très simple de raconter sa journée
ma mère et moi on a raté une occasion de
pouvoir améliorer nos liens affectifs et
c'est ça ce que se passe dans les
familles
c'est à dire que vous et vous allez si
vous le pratiquez vous pourrez découvrir
vous même que vos enfants donc recevoir
beaucoup de bien de fait mais vous aussi
alors moi je pourrais faire une
conférence de trois heures sur tous les
bienfaits que vous pourrez observer et
sentir en vous-même devait le membre des
nues rond dans le cerveau la santé
physique et mentale améliorer les liens
affectifs enrichit la mémorisation mis
en place la mémoire les laisse la parole
expression orale ce qui créa meilleure
estime de soi
et puis les valeurs dont les compteurs
il ya mille mille choses mais ils
viennent fait que j'ai découverte et que
j'espère que peut être vous aussi vous
découvrirez mais comme il faut terminer
et que les conteuses sont très bavarde
et bienne j'aimerais juste terminer en
disant les bons comptes font les bons
amis
et moi je dirais un peu plus les bons
contes font des bonnes familles et donc
il me reste juste vous souhaiter bonne
compte innovation